so we went through glass onions entire
wardrobe and found costumes that were
tied with hidden meanings gorgeous
vintage fabrics and peculiar wardrobe
pieces that give away major film secrets
wow so like our girl the leading lady
Janelle Monae for example it was so
crucial to be able to run for her that's
why her entire outfit was built you
guessed it all around her shoes you know
the ones her Valentino Flats you come
here your Gucci Flats telling us
Valentina and then everything else her
suits the accessories it all came after
the shoes and Helen's sophisticated
suits and super elegant dresses were not
actually designed for Helen at all but
for her twin sister Andy and if you put
these two sisters side by side you'd see
that they're like radically different
from each other so as you know during
nearly the entire movie Helen pretended
to be Andy and that's why the idea of
Helen would have gotten to Andy's closet
and taken her clothes was heavily
incorporated into her costume design to
highlight their differences they did
subtler nods you know with makeup and
nail color and such now while that was a
cool experience it must have been so
much fun designing looks for birdie with
the Bold prints and the bright colors
and the jewelry her floor length gown is
designed to be a visual effect within
itself like that moment when the
director Ryan Johnson asks her to spin
and all these rainbow colors just come
to life oh it's awesome it almost is
like an illusion it's almost like a
visual effect in and of itself okay and
another interesting fact here Birdie's
entire wardrobe was handmade except for
her bikini of course we had to figure
out where this bikini was from it's the
Andrea ayama Mulan orange bikini Kate
Hudson wanted to look Flawless and so
she would just eat cucumber and feta and
didn't touch her aperol Spritz till
after her bikini scene and on the very
other end of the spectrum there's Claire
her entire wardrobe was just a rack of
beige because you know we all think of
politicians and think beige well in the
script they actually used the words
politician Bay age to describe her
wardrobe I said I wanted to be the sad
trumpet noise of costumes in this movie
she thought she was going to get some
glamorous exciting costumes for Claire
but that definitely was not the case and
like this movie is so specific that
Claire's character translates even in
the way she wears her mask as a
politician part of that is she needs to
show her face to voters so there's a lot
of on and off with her mask while she
still tries to be mindful of the
pandemic rules she's very conscious of
the of the Mask etiquette does the way
you wear a mask say something about you
like birdie in the beginning of the
movie she's throwing this wild pandemic
party so there's no surprise that she's
wearing a glamorous lace mask that's
almost like a jewelry piece we can't hug
right this girl is social distancing in
style and Lionel the scientist who has
not only one but two k-95s
speaking of Lionel did you notice the
wishbone pin on his lapel so the actor
who plays him Leslie Odom Jr actually
found that in a thrift store in
Connecticut and so Jenny took that and
had a few identical pieces made for the
film the wishbone symbolizes luck and
Adventure which is obviously a reference
to the movie's plot and there's also
this practicality to Lionel that's shown
in a scene by the pool that shirt is the
same shirt that I wear under the suit
while other outfits were not so
practical and we couldn't not talk about
Duke Speedo when Jenny was designing his
poolside outfit that was the first
costume piece that came to mind
everything else The holster the beach
wrap the Crocs all came after Poor Dave
Batista was so embarrassed in this
little outfit he couldn't disguise
anything in that Speedo I'm blushing now
thinking about it I feel like I've worn
less I wrestled in front of millions of
people wearing just a little but for
some reason I just was really
self-conscious about this damn Speedo
and before we jump ship on the poolside
outfits you may have noticed Daniel
Craig's costumes we're the only ones not
caught up to the present day Craig
Sports a modest much more modest than
Duke Speedo blue and white striped
matching set surrounded by other bikinis
and Speedos it's very much his character
a detective stuck in the past trying to
decipher the meaning of the cases that
continue to haunt him and his outfit in
the arrival scene is very particular too
and almost a little on the nose of
Jacques tati and Cary Grant from To
Catch a Thief when Daniel had a chat
with director Ryan Johnson I saw like
the high-waisted pants and I'm like is
that little uh Carey grounding To Catch
a Thief back in the 1920s up until the
1950s high-waisted pants were pretty
much the norm for men's everyday wear so
just like high-waisted pants linen is in
costume designer Jenny Egan gave miles a
ton of linen cashmere and some natural
fibers to keep him grounded in reality
this is actually because he's a fraud
he's using these grounding fibers to
mask what he really is I mean
you know there's no reality there at all
okay like when he's on the beach playing
the guitar looking like the holistic
Guru of healing such a contrast to his
actual character that's not natural at
all he's trying so hard to look like
something he's not even down to the very
fabric of his costume Jenny seated Clues
everywhere she's added unexpected layers
to enrich the story and they're so
easily overlooked if you're not paying
good attention Glass Onion was mostly
shot in Greece and it was hot very hot
this plays a huge factor in the way the
actors were dressed and you might be
surprised to find out that one of
Janelle Monae's most Chic outfits is
actually a swimsuit in Disguise it's a
swimming suit but it's belted and I just
love this fabric so much Jenny Egan had
to be mindful of the Fabrics they used
because the temperature in Greece at
that time was absolutely scorching when
they filmed that was the exact thinking
behind this outfit I think that was the
most difficult thing with shooting
outside AI when it was that hot now
would you have noticed otherwise that it
was a swimsuit the costume designers of
the film sort of made it their mission
statement to support mom and pop shops
on Etsy after Chris Evans sweater went
viral in the last film soon Etsy shops
left and right were selling out of
similar sweater designs and honestly we
find that so wholesome oh and we found
detective blanc's neck scarf in case you
wanted to emulate his iconic style
they're just these small local people
that make these beautiful bandanas okay
but there was one that wasn't from an
Etsy shop and that was the one from the
dinner scene at the end it was handmade
from vintage silk we guess we can
forgive them for the one we're changing
gears entirely here like can we say
Festival girl that was the major
inspiration behind Whiskey's sassy look
and it all started with a fringe bag and
a pair of boots the actor Madeline Klein
was in a fitting with Jenny and took
note of the two pieces like right away
oh this girl has not moved on from 2014
or 15. she stayed in her 2015 Coachella
era and has never left whiskeys cut out
tops crochet and Fringe tells us from
the beginning that she's young at least
younger than everyone else and she's
more focused on her looks also did you
notice Birdie's subtle reaction to
Whiskey's Presence by the pool we've
been conditioned to say oh look at the
younger fitter version of what I used to
be that was Kate Hudson's discreet way
of highlighting the tense dynamic
between the two characters I thought it
was quite interesting the way Kate
played that it was really spot on all
right and we're gonna Circle back to
detective Blanc real quick he wakes up
and puts on a pristine white shirt suit
tie the works why do you think there's a
sort of psychology behind that which is
about being prepared being armored and
ready to go he's a detective agency is
it because he's prepared or is there
something more Sinister behind it he's
ready or he's a psychopath yeah one of
the other and we may never know so did
you enjoy the hidden meanings and little
Easter eggs Jenny Egan hid throughout
the film with glass onions handmade
costumes the vintage fabrics and the
nods to Classic Movies it's really hard
not to analyze every single piece of
clothing but which outfit was your
favorite